aliens are real we actually this is no
joke a a whistleblower has come forward
a very reputable Source saying non-human
spacecrafts are real and we have them
wow ladies and gentlemen we're not going
to talk about the Biden family at all
because this news is so much more
important and appealing to the general
public so I'm really excited to get into
this uh Alien stuff and uh in all
seriousness both of these stories happen
today and you have to wonder why it is
there's a very very credible Source
coming out saying non-human aircraft or
or spacecraft or whatever have are in
The Possession and being withheld from
Congress whoo yeah because maybe we have
the house oversight committee saying
we're having the FBI warning that if the
identity of the Whistleblower of the
informant is revealed he will be killed
because of the evidence of corruption
that he has brought forward against the
Biden family a major bribery Scandal
which we're now learning involves shell
companies